[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Sandin, şovumun çok
dışında olanlardan kaynaklanıyor onlara temel endüstri
esenin işi gibi bir dinlemede
bazı anneler benim öğemi seçtikten sonra sekresyon ol
takvim ol sadece ilgili
imzalı bir albüm sembolü mevcut robot çarpışması
meydana gelecek ve  ASEAN yıllarında biri ben
değil Müslüman köpekbalıkları tarafından gönderilen bir muhtıra
bu arada dinle Bubba'yı daha önce görmüş
o bir Louisiana gibi ısmarlama
Chicano'yu satın al HTC genç tomada
Marisol'de Scylla diller
[Müzik]
ve
[Müzik] diyor
ve gel  içeride
[Müzik]
bkz
hiçbir şey
[Müzik]
baybel beni
ben uydurdum annem
[Müzik]
[Müzik
] onları gökyüzüne
[Müzik]
sen
Ah
[Müzik]
Dr.  Ziegler'in yaz ayrılığı iyi
adam en iyi EGC Kim L Angelo Aldo kadar
erken sapma düşük görüş George
Gershwin onlar kral ayrılışlar olmalı
ama biz birini kovalayacağız ben de
sadece
[Müzik]
eh tema senin mektubun yeniden kökenli
yani sallayarak sanam
AK oldu oğlunla mücadele et
kimin aktif olduğunu gör Ah
düşman kim bu aptal biri
Goodin anne Ganesha aileye bir detay
ama sen bizim Ganesh'imizsin merhaba balo al
[Müzik]
oh evet
evet Papa Zulu ya Hristiyansın ya da
the Sun ba ba
yani Drupal ve ben ya onları birleştirmek zorundaydık,
senin kutunu birleştirmek zorunda mıydın, o fırının kötü olduğundan daha çılgınca kaçar mı
Dini bizim makinemiz temiz merdiven penisi
makinemizde sıska ben uyu Larry
bana bu ver
[Müzik
] sesin adamı sen  beni kahvaltıya getirdin
um
nefis
[Müzik]
hangi sayıların iyi olacağını söyledin gün
ışığında alıcılar olacak
[Müzik]
hizmete devam et
tarafından
[Müzik]
[Alkış]  ]
tamam
[Müzik]
m  e
sen Serena
[Müzik]
ama
evet
[Müzik]
Dedim ki
Kutsal Jacque
[Müzik]
[Alkış]